[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hulu
puisque j'ai acheté non c'est un
chapelet non oui alors que ça peut être
utilisé comme s'appliquant à oui comme
vous comme martin edge est bien c'est
que c'est un objet ultra moderne avec un
truc ultra anciens sûr tu fais comme les
grecs ou les voulait être sûre que tu
sait attendre et moi je suis plus mal
élevés que toi parce que à l'eau et
l'autre on met ce que j'ai les gels
interviews des américains
je suis désolé mais c'est obligé à cause
du décalage bourgeois et table parce que
le livre sort
sera en amérique là bas windows ouais
comme ça parle un peu de ça les
intéresse oui tiens pourquoi un français
fait ça alors que nous on l'a pas fait
et tu vas pas j'y vais mais là c'est tu
sais c'est avant d'y aller il faut
préparer le terrain la magie verne avril
c'est un rien à ginette avec cette venue
quand même un écrivain internationale
maintenant tu as dit qu'il arrive
hirscher dit là des éditions dans tous
les pays du monde en turquie en slovénie
en slovénie ça marche très bien élevé ni
très star en slovénie non énorme énorme
en finlande en lettonie c'est à riga je
conseille le fashion club lounge de riga
ah ouais c'est bien trop discrète
chasser téléphone pour vous décevoir il
ya des photos que c'est sympa dit dont
10,1 pas le plus simple objet te faire
prendre en photo avec candeloro pour
avoir ça quand même il ya sari et en
même temps ce qui est sympa c'est son
prix zéro france des ressentis voila
voila je sais qui et amassé une photo
avec candeloro ça a donc un prix en fait
c'est quand même un prix
c'est beaucoup plus cher que ce qu'on a
quand même appris ouais et ça fait des
photos fait des progrès si je vous
l'avais des films ouais elle fait
défiler demandé si j'avais un truc
qu'ils fassent des fautes hausse du
nombre voir des photos d'un appareil
photo oui mais non mais tout ça à bonne
école
moi je vais te montrer les films que
j'ai fait avec mon portable tu as fais
des films à huy par exemple j'ai la
cathédrale de cologne ouais voilà
falloir d'abord jean
attend non ça va bouger à recevoir mais
voilà c'est diakhaté son album je me dis
ah non c'est vrai que c'est bien
maintenant mais je
vais tuer de cusset
si l'on veut qu'à cologne a pas que des
cathédrales quand même si elle tend
qu'est-ce que j'ai tout raconté des
choses j'ai des choses à présent ça
c'est une fille à charnay à qui danse
dans un cylindre rempli d'eau eau avec
un masque à oxygène
c'est intéressant
ah oui tu fais du chum et je pensais
j'ai un projet pour coincer un long
métrage avait envie de faire un long
métrage filmé uniquement avec un
portable ce serait le premier long
métrage uniquement réalisé avec un
téléphone lors que taddei qui filme avec
une aisance de toute caméra très cinéma
mais taddei sympa mais c'est pareil
c'est comme toi à ces marchés n'est pas
simple quand il tournait vous un peu
vers le 21e siècle oui bon choix ouais
bon parce que jean paul rouve au
quatrième étage merci s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
oui
et puis
et
[Musique]
il
ouais là dans les américains les
américains par axa fou mais
alimente à fès et l'emmener avec vous
mais il faut il faut que je branche
parce que nous portons la plus de
batterie
allô
allô allô
yes
eyes on the way
[Musique]
you
know it's better américain life to live
too peut
toujours causer un moba swiss attend bon
alors je reviens tout à l'heure je peux
mettre dans ton bureau wen a tué dans
l'oeuf et bonsoir très bien savez-vous
très bien je dis bonjour à jour par sa
voix tu sais quoi il ya les américains
us american alors les américains
accordent
des crédits conditionné jean monnet
messieurs j'arrive chez moi quand
j'arrive chez des parents mais enfin
monsieur c'est nous c'est papa et maman
oui mesdames messieurs n'ont pas
mesdames messieurs papa et maman moi ça
va ça va
assez bien c'est un bijou de portable un
an ces normes j'en suis extrêmement fier
sûr que ça humanise le portable
évidemment nation vous savez un objet
familier comme un petit animal et puis
aussi ça va bien si ce côté turc ou
grecs grecque que ça toute la journée
bon ça va alors ouais ouais ça va avec
depardieu l'avant deux fils a vu le
chinois huawei west ham nous pas c'est
vrai enfin moi ça me surprend pas
tous les fidèles t'aimons tu viennes ou
pluvieuses mon vieux démons de chez
drucker non c'est vrai c'est vrai que je
t'embrouille carnahan c'est vrai que
j'ai toujours cru que tu avais dit
arriver là je suis ravi parce que dit
d'en face à face à depardieu était pas
tu pas ridicule qua non mais ça se passe
bien et que sinon non plus les jours le
rôle comme acteur tu vois
voilà non je suis content at your man on
a la santé du film la santé du film
areola ouais t'as peur en donnant
wassila ben voila je flippe papa à
flipper c'est quoi je me suis je pensais
à 7 heures dans le train ce qu'on fait
c'est la tournée on va voir les gens
provinces et tous et je me rends compte
quand je tourne je fis passagers tout va
bien j'ai à dire de jouer tout mais
vraiment je suis cool et en fait je
flippe après quand je suis complice ils
vont sortir j'arrive pas à faire de m
j'arrive pas à mettre des distances en
fait encore non je trouve ça assez bien
l'histoire du cette espèce de deux
heures c'est ce qu'il ya dans le film de
mathilde et de baudriers aux côtés
d'anna c'est à dire oui mais c'est
pareil quoi c'est l'histoire l ai vu une
fois du côté des mecs dans le film avec
depardieu c'est ça une fois les vues du
côté des nanas dans le film de de
mathilde et si tu veux c'est là c'est
grave quoi cc je trouve ça vachement
grave non mais sérieux
grave attend les hommes et les femmes et
se parlent plus n'arrive plus à se
parler c'est que tous d'ailleurs ce qui
est bien dans le film c'est qu'en fait
la vraie histoire d'amour elle entre
depardieu et toi tu si ça plus qu'entre
vous et les femmes qui savent c'est que
l'amitié prend le dessus puisqu'on
n'arrive plus à avoir des relations
hommes-femmes ouais c'est étonnant ça
ouais c'est vachement c'est en même
temps très bon le film est très bien
mais c'est raide et espérons quand même
oui c'est sur un fond très noir un baby
morquio you so
bas et non non mais be mais big sound
vario pz into américaine perth mais vous
entendez bien tous les deux non rôle
qu'est-ce qu'on s'entende ouais on sort
on voit sur route us et ouais ça fait
dix jours sur du jour et ça s'est super
bien passé mais tu sais dans le regard
tu sais je me dis ah oui c'est comme les
gens que tu connais depuis longtemps
c'était potes et puis un jour tu dis
mais quand est ce qu'on s'est rencontré
la première a battu c'est plus parce que
c'était tellement évident tu te souviens
plus et avec gérard wey ça se passe
super et ça se voit et les mecs c'est
qu'il est real ces deux jeunes mecs
c'est leur premier film il avait fait
des courts métrages avant - qui est
vachement bien les petits souliers ça
s'appelle avec jamais des aiguades et
voilà il m'a envoyé le scénario
simplement j'ai lu j'ai trouvé ça bien
j'ai appelé gérard enfin que toi
alors si je ils m'ont dit bon qui
pourrait faire le troll je dis aux âges
gérard depardieu se serait bien
justement je le connais un peu genre ou
deux sur eux et
gm passant par taha bringer début six
mois avant et j'ai appelé alain chabat
jeudi alain est ce que tu pourrais
appeler gérard pour lui dire que je veux
jouer en me disant je suis donné son
portable je t attends non non je tu vois
je veux pas déranger quoi donc j'ai
laissé un message à 2 par dieu je lui ai
dit bonjour c'est jean paul rouve des
robins des bois on s'est vus sur eux je
suis dit tu vois depuis six mois sans
souffler un peu or il a fait qu'un film
c'est plus il m'a rappelé et il a été
adorable commune jean il tourne avec toi
défunt des choses à doha mais lui l'aimé
heures je trouve depuis quelques temps
là il a eu une période un peu zarbi et
l'a déjà fait deux trois films ou les
biens le film avec de naviguer bien si
tu vois le final de 36 il est vachement
bien ouais fort voilà 36 voix là bas il
est mieux là je pas ce qu'il s'est passé
là il va bien quoi je crois mais en même
temps si c'est comme les champions c'est
comme si dan à un moment il mais pas de
but on dit que tu me tues mais pas de
buts en ce moment mais c'est un être
humain aussi il a le droit aussi d'être
un peu moins bien mais non mais tu vois
ça non c'est vrai que tu dis moi tu te
fais un grand compliment ça fait un peu
penser à deux verres et depardieu quand
on arrête ça mais ouais mais moi ça dit
tout ce qu'ils trouvent à 1,6050 dix ans
c'est vrai c'est vrai moi ça me touche
j'avais l'impression de revoir les deux
connards ensemble quoi tu as i way des
valseuses ouais ouais alors on n'est pas
la même génération c'est vrai mais dans
les quelque chose
ouais il ya quelque chose on s'entend
bien quoi un truc de tête de filiation
je sais pas si tu as l'impression d'être
de la même famille et pas d'une image il
a fait 150 filles en effet 15 mais ça
passe quoi avec ce mec et les césar
alors
ben oui pourquoi pour podium en second
rôle c'est bien ça c'est trop la balle
je trouve un peu c'est bien un podium je
suis super content je suis perdrait pas
je veux pas savoir que ça fait plaisir
ça fait voilà je peux pas rien dire
d'autre ouais bon les césars attend l
origine rom mais des cno mais déjà c'est
tellement bien quoi
de césar peut-être arrête ces bons rails
sérieux ni marrant c'est pas savoir
vainqueur à ba les parents à dunkerque a
donné comme tous les ans et un musicien
musée chez moi souligné antonio visité
3 euros si tu rentres
ça nous sépare
terry a
oui bonsoir bonsoir c'est judith
godrèche quatrième étage complet
capable d'éditer deux
ok toujours et c'est american quoi awel
hautes attentes mais sérieux là
enfin depuis septembre il est en train
de faire son interview de cet égard je
vais faire ici son interview carrément
ouais bon un magazine je faire si
j'arrive
[Musique]
ouah ouah
habitué
ça fait penser au film il a tu vas zorn
la bouffe et et on oublie la voûte est
jetée rive oublier la bouteille s'est
enquéri déjà maladie jambes dans
l'esprit de leur nez dans les briefings
ça va
et j'arrive au téléphone
ap lance un appel en absence
maurice barthélémy tu connais jean paul
rault
chine rappelle casier bonjour la bouche
et avec les robins gc ca c'est ça c'est
ça nous remet ça les robes en lainage
tenu aussi tu étais sûr qu un retour à
des déchets
deux chiens
non écoute tu es tu encore plus belle
enceinte je pense voilà
ça ne va bien des tracteurs à moi je
suis un acteur ouais mais c'est chouette
les acteurs il ya des césar et un wydad
et enfin un an j'ai dit bientôt 2
ajoutez à
ces perfusions toi tu votes pas aussi
fait partie de la grande famille du
cinéma je m étonne donc fait un très bon
film quarante mille ha bah voilà alors
on était content parce qu'on visait gaz
à casablanca driver way 40 mon visait
les 30000 ouais on a dépassé on est
derniers incidents étaient très contents
le producteur et du très très content à
bientôt six mois
et là tu vas faire plus avec papale
j'espère c'est l'objectif s'appelle papa
oui exactement avec alain chabat avec
alain et le pitch c'est quoi c'est
l'histoire d'un papa
d'un père et de son fils qui traverse la
france est en fait c'est on découvre au
fur et à mesure du voyage leur secret
c'est tout c'est vraiment un film tout
simple ces caractères driven ça
s'appelle c'est à dire il n'y a pas de
pitch énorme quand c'est ce caractère
direct j'ai appris deux mots avec chabat
ces caractères jason c'est à dire le
film n'y a pas un pitch énorme mais
c'est les personnages qui font le truc
quoi car j'avais et l'autre c'est no
brainer j'ai un mot que j'adore encore
de quoi briser le cerveau un no brainer
c'est un pitch ou ya rien à dire quoi
c'est no brainer c'est pas la peine de
réfléchir c'est bien no brainer a pas
mal c'est bien toi tu fais no brainer en
ce moment qu'est-ce qu'il a fait lui non
non je n'en ai pas
feiglin obreno c'est un truc évident
comme ça sans réfléchir rapport
spontanée un o'brian on peut dire le
film que tu fais avec depardieu là c'est
un caractère de nom c'est un bout
d'imovie c'est un banshee je n'ai pas
dit mot bien film de potes veut dans la
vie voilà ça c'est un voeu jimmy wales
alors ok en fait le buzz the movie un
body molly et toi c'est que ça manque un
rappeur c'est quoi c'est un bide
américains s'imposent
aucune répartie quand il dit grosso veut
c'est qu'il n'a aucune valeur tu veux
des partis arabes à
city
ya des notes et did not think about that
et 10 mois et marina la coucher ou pas
bien sûr ah bon parce que
tu as eu son bac cette année celle à
quelques mois ah oui ça y est on ne sait
pas ce que c'est mais on n'a pas trouvé
encore de tout bizarre
qu'est ce que tu veux est-ce que ça se
passe bien entre vous avec judith écoute
à
l'aller 1 1 l ai jamais le téléphone là
ça c'est sûr
bah écoute away à du saumon c'est pour
quand la fin avril
vachement des trucs attends tu rigoles
regarde
tourteaux décortiqué concombres les
tomates
j'ai 14 ans de la naissance du bébé en
fonction de la sortie du film comme ça
me servais impôts gala exactement tueur
est donc match le film va sortir assez
maurice et je dis ceci judith ils ont 2
rue lui là un film elle a un enfant
exact mais un truc à faire 1 1 comme la
janis jean michel jarre ou ils
séparent ils vont pas bien et 800 mhz un
disque un mois après c'est super
pratique ça comme truc s'il ya peu de
chances définitivement je crois que
cette semaine les yeux
[Musique]
je regarde par un dieu parce que bon
ces mecs au cul
quand j'étais très jeune oh merde je
vais avoir une droit une histoire d'aix
elle a plein d'histoires
d'aix-en-provence tu parles de la ligue
bien sûr exactement
passé sur un tournage et j'avais eu une
aventure avec un et quinze jeunes
garçons un rocker matin annonce eric
chelle bourget très rocker il vient me
chercher en mode des couleurs dans le
gros truc c'est qu'il avait une moto et
france jean-luc les nôtres quelle moto
ça me faisait vraiment rêver surtout
qu'à l'époque j'étais très
très intello et où je parle aux
musulmans des pâles avec jean-paul
lafont s'est pas vu depuis longtemps on
a le droit passé de t'intéresser en
passes intéressantes en histoire
laquelle voilà on va zy alors vas-y ton
ex
que mon amant gm cherche en moto sur le
tournage mon studio
et je me bats avec le moto et mon mec
appel sur le tournage parce qu'il
doutait un peu que c'est des trucs
bizarres il a parlé judith oued la part
de cubains sont avec un an la partie
voilà un beau tour
oui
bonsoir fait chuter leurs manies
mathilde seigner
4e et josh rct
bonjour mesdames
soit pour soi
besson firent augmente aussi complet
non
merci placer la manière is not to do it
respekt for victims of corse is one of
them 2
dramatique d'un jour
[Musique]
bonjour ça va enrichir je ne connais pas
et néon matériau douala qui sait s'il
fait si l'exercice du film arnaquer
j'ai phanou
il faut pas l'énerver
j'ai très bien bravo hein mais toi aussi
c'est sur l'amitié c'est à dire en
2003 a mis à part il paraît qu'ils ont
pas de nike sont pas de mec assis
là elle l a pas de mac elle est là un
pin kung fu pas une elle est super sympa
son mec le peintre lui il faut rien il
se lève le matin je ne lève pas le matin
à l'époque la femme parfaite et puis y'a
pas rio qui vit avec un mec qui a un
espèce de deux winners ce terrible
financière n'a pas d'ambition d'ailleurs
qu'elle n'a pas d'ambition
ces trois dévalorisation de plein droit
sont copines c'est génial ce modeste et
3 c'est non c'est vachement bien
maintenant c'est super dur oui pareil
c'était assez voire était sorti bah
ouais comme suit soleil j'étais troublé
parce que finalement que je me dis mais
c'est vrai
teasé d'un seul coup tu me rends compte
humanitaire
médicale thierry qui te rends pas compte
de ce à quoi tu te rends compte que ça
que maintenant si un bond de la
difficulté de vivre avec la une un peu
pour ça qu'on a fait
je me suis mariée une première fois
j'avais 20 ans on voit là j'ai 10 ans et
à 30 ans après je me suis remarié que
béatrice tabah 20 ans non mais c'est
terrible je pense que c'est grave est
quelque chose de cassé entre les hommes
et les femmes un message alors qui sait
je suis camara ce qui est marié avec toi
il s'appelle comment son nom de famille
de mal avec les ruses ah c'est pas comme
ça que ça se prononce faut qu'ils
changent de nom tout de suite isabelle
robard télémélé cuzon prononcer
sur le tournage avec d'énormes marques
de griffes dans le dos c'est qu'il a des
très gros et ce rapport sexuel la nuit
non si je te jure je
lui dis que je ne vous le dirais
mais
il faisait de la provoc non mais avec sa
nana c'est de la fausse trouve ça
n'attend pas possible de laisser nos
lits la wii on l'attend un don pour y
faire c'est de la provoc un nom il avait
peut-être tailler les arbres de son
jardin laver et l'autre c'est qui ce qui
fait le mari d'anne parillaud thierry
thierry neuvic et
vous savez quand et le belge avec
l'huile feixiang remplacée par celle ci
tous les bénefs de paris sont dans ce
film sauf évidemment change pas les mots
récemment
la scène quand on ne baise avec terrine
à quel point qu'elle raconte pourquoi je
prends pas ça c'est pas ma scène
préférée immofonds sont fous maintenant
c'est super réaliste quand même parce
que nana qui pensent à autre chose et
une âme et le monde le montrer attends
je suis forcément mais bon fou rire
super réaliste un ticket en train de
penser à son dîner est ce qu'il va y
avoir à manger si vous ressentez vous
croyez qu'il aimait qu'on pense pas
autre chose des fois aussi pourquoi je
voulais évidemment pas rires
bien joué on pense à nouveau oui si j'y
pense je vous ai à des fantasmes elles
allaient bon train c'est pas vrai mais
me souvenais match aller mais compensait
des trucs comme les impôts pour pas
jouer parce que si la pensée habitons
jouit donc voilà rester mais on pense à
ma grand mère l'a joint tout de suite
alors que le roi c'est une question à
laquelle fait référence à patrick fiori
pour pas joué voilà c'est ça voilà donc
penser à comprendre et à ses trousses
pour les bienvenus ça c'est une nouvelle
question à quoi pensez-vous pour palais
du rire il sait bien c'est les impôts qu
est ce qu il ya de voter contre un tiers
provisionnel mais impopulaire des impôts
tu t'es bon fogiel
tu les aimes aussi par deux vaches on a
su bien sûr
m
[Musique]
enfin les tribus bonnart au quatrième
étage à lui
c'est très marrant quand même c'est
pourquoi tous les films français c'est
pour les questions tournent autour de ce
à quoi que tu vois le cas parce que ces
problèmes
mais parce que ces sociologues juste les
gens
films qui sortent qui tourne autour du
cou je te quitte je te laisse te
retrouves je t'aime je t'aime plus tout
va bien aussi oui il est le fils de jean
iborra talent voilà
qui vachement bien ouais j'ai lu en dvd
inc barnes and because may be fayyad
forte l'aisne we do not have done it
[Musique]
sa reprise est là
nos parents et j'ai des fourmis a surgi
obligé de rester parce que je peux pas
partir '
[Musique]
verdict
c'est pour toi tu connais pas le héros
nique bonsoir ligue 1
mais en étudiant la scea le journal lé
qui travaille sur paris première qui
fait la mode sur paris pour l'iphone
interview
l'état met ou sentimentalement à non non
non non non non le film cultive l'échec
c'est vrai moi là bas si la
france est ce que je réussis le mieux
voilà c'est ça s'est passé comme ça
c'est pas dans la vie mais c'est dans
les filets trop courtisé et à un moment
ça non sur le tournage si tu voyais les
mecs en battant ça
nous a bien sûr mais ça faisait trop et
que je crois pas toi je prends des
femmes en général vous êtes trop et oui
moi je suis trop exigeante et très
chiante aussi donc faut dire que je
reconnais moi je suis apte à chien tu
vois là vous êtes rencontrés dans un
speed dating tous les deux mois
quasiment quasiment avait sont des amis
qui nous ont plein nord a laissé comme
je peux dire que vous appuyez tout est
très speed entre nous on fait toute
façon très scripté des gens que vous ont
présenté andré ont jamais présenté oui
si ça marche tu as marre c'est comme ça
tu reçois pourquoi on ne fait pas ce
soir à moulins 6 ha lady à judith sur
votre question ils ont dit à judith on
va te présenter un mec qui n'a pas de
nanas
et langil à ça bloque quand on dit ça
non moi je viens truc on fera tout seul
c'était pas le seul argument est en
train de faire le film de harel et tout
à coup on était en train d'attendre il
se regarde et il dit ce genre tu vois
que je pense a dit ouais vous moi aussi
et ils ont eu la même idée en même temps
de quoi de vous deux ouais pourtant ce
n'était pas évident sur le pas mais vous
vous avez
l'idée
mais après tout de suite coup de foudre
et donc ils m'ont dit il faut absolument
contre environ comptent présenter moi je
pense qu'on ferait sait qui et je
pensais qu'il était juif et alors j'aime
bien l'idée
dans le problème c'est que le jour de
notre rencontre j'ai mis des talons très
hauts il m'avait pas prévenu qu'il était
très très petit les bas côtés du peuple
mais il est de taille modeste je suis de
deux textes ans d'annuités standard bien
je fais 1 40 comme tout le monde l'a vu
voilà il est normal mais voilà il est
obligé d'aller en dessous type où il
peut aller dans les bagages doctement
dans l'avion s'il a plein de veauchette
un but sur sa pratique
je suis dégoûté j'aime voir et il m'a
demandé un enfant c'est rare un homme
qui ont annoncé génial à la wes image un
mot assez fort ça tu vois je dis reste
actionner les
super bien moi ah bon tu vas bien aussi
du nord
puisqu'il a connu au plus tu fais le
malin mais tu vas connais une actrice lb
yolande moreau tu estimes pays avec
d'une fille du rpt les initiales non
le lidar nom assez drôle que l'islam non
ici superbe occultes et ça c'est super
bowl du mois alors dans kiss et l arrêt
soit eux contre j'ai un problème je te
dirai ça depuis longtemps je te donne
mon bijou de téléphone si tu me le dis
au nom aussi si tu te donne mon bijou de
téléphone se donne tout de suite non lui
dis jamais parce qu'après il matin à
l'avenir
s'écrit ce qu'il faut faire
c'est fini qu'en maintenant c'est fini
entre eux et jamais arrêtés pas très
chaud la chimie bel et bon tu les
laisses tournée c'est que la balle je
tiens moi c'est ouvert
qui s'énerve
mais
voilà je sais pas où je suis sans voix
je me mets à la place de xavi
mais comment tu veux qu'on soit
passé mais j'ai pas mon nom mois
j'hallucine tu es
là bas
même pas alors il
aujourd'hui est pas là
mon bureau ecla il allait il est malin
tiens ouais bah tiens tu vas mourir
gens veulent savoir
pourquoi j'envoie qu'est ce qui se passe
sur la boisson
tentij pdg contre amplifié par rapport
mais je fais chier ce que tu disais même
le chili tout est fini entre les hommes
et les femmes non mais je suis pas
d'accord avec toi mais trois heures
entre nous surtout c'est ce qui change
c'est que en cantons mais moi je vois la
génération de mes parents et tout de
suite marier avec tu te marier jeune
c'est plus compliqué mais quand il ya un
problème dans le couple d'essayer de le
résoudre et qui ne séparait pas
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que les
gens vont pas bien ici non mais il ya un
peu plus d'an là exactement mais voilà
il doit tu sais pas ce service est
tout à fait rejoindre et plus d'efforts
l'atelier soir michel marty lisez les
trucs sérieux non mais dis des trucs
non nathan et nous on est
des fous rires ça nous réussit tout à
l'heure maintenant si tu le mérites
s'appelle tu fais semblant je suis sur
moi vous séparer
d'eric et laurent
non ils en sont libres sur le 11
septembre le lancement
est venu je l'avais prévenu
j'avais un rendez vous téléphonique
aux séries non mais je l'aï dit ailleurs
mme anodina où
c'est toi qui appelait gueux qui
appelait fait son chemin à ce qu'au
niveau forfait c'est l'horreur
je cherche le nom de la mode de jeu
c'est justement de là
j'ai trouvé
non pas parce qu'on fait les gens soient
à chinon jean-paul quoi c'est une fille
qui a publié un livre chez chez frédéric
à ces ballons tu as l'air mal jean-paul
la rue parce qu'on veut dire on peut
dire une chose elle est pas mal du tout
bon allez vas-y on va l'entrée on parle
d'autre chose à la maison et moi je
respecte tu vois tu vois comme on dit
comme quoi je changeais toi à l'époque
ce choix comme je tirais pas le nom de
la marque de rouge voilà
les initiales bon les initiales initial
tiens c'est drôle c'est se dit sur cette
assiette il ya un bcm
piret béatrice
bon papa à tendre la main commence à
taper
j'attendais je suis dit si je crève
brauman point com
un site internet pour les mecs qui
aiment faire l'amour avec les femmes
enceintes
jusqu'au petit matin mathilde est génial
vous dis moi tu fais sur internet je
suis content c'est comme si c'était
contre
je sais que ça va dire je sais que ça
veut rien dire cela dit c'est vrai qu'il
y en a marre de l'électricité mais non
pas la bouger avant je comprenais pas je
n'ai pas envie de me mettre alors si
vous voulez jouer 50 dans ma vie là
j'aime pas internet alors tu peux être
ni pour ni contre ces pâles probable oui
je sais c'est comme si on était contre
le téléphone ou contre un truc comme ça
c'est j'adore ce débat oui moi ça on
n'est pas assez intelligent pour toi
moi j'adore ce débat que les filles
entre elles sont beaucoup plus salaces
que nous nous on est assez puggy contre
non mais je refuse que l'ami de matinée
me fasse et je fais passer des messages
par texto genre je suis dit mon truc je
suis contre
je lui dis tu veux pas que ma moore me
me fasse des sodomies mais pourquoi tu
lui dises or elle aime pas et c'est tout
geste
toi
ainsi c'est normal non mais je crois que
maurice tu as envie d'en parler
je me sens pas du tout mal à l'aise
on peut ne pas aimer internet et mails à
sudo enfin tu vois c'est franchement
c'est normal vous faites lui tirer
dessus mais pas les vrais sujets moi
mais parce que franchement chantier sado
c'est plutôt marie claire c'est un sujet
tabou donc ah bon ces demandes ont fait
les points comptent pas encore je pense
que c'est encore un sujet tabou je vois
tes yeux la joie bien que c'est un sujet
tabou bon voilà mais je pense à l'esat
en la découpant ses doigts semabla on a
parlé sodomie on est allés loin on est
on est c'est du lourd là là est-ce qu'on
peut laisser du temps mais des fois tu
sais pas comment
on apporte des godemichets je te dis pas
le truc on est acteur j'ai changé au
taquet moi je vais t'étonner
ça ne m'intéresse pas tellement non non
c'est dominer la défense qui commence
par ça va détonner dans le ventre c'est
un vrai fantasme des hommes non
j'espère c'est de miser ou de
sur nos villes et tu sais pourquoi c'est
leur côté
pdc plus étroit sinon c'est quoi cette
expression ses plus étroits
la sodomie n'est pas la panacée aïe ça
tu me surprend tuez pas fan je préfère
la panacée à la sodomie non c'est pas
mon truc ultime doit tourner le truc
vraiment landini sme c'est celle à moyen
long diniz
démagogie jeudi la démagogie essaie de
se remettre les fils dans cinq ans mais
bon sang brochu m'habitue mal à
l'organisme ouais les genres et son fils
est subie au nom les quads et les hommes
ah ben c'est comme dans lunes de fiel ah
ouais ouais comme dans lunes de fiel je
suis une référence que quelqu'un est
super excitée vidéo
tous les mots qu'il faut pas dire
toujours pas élucidées
oui mathilde oui et je n'ai pas pu et
alors à jouer quelqu'un qui te dis oh
sur les toilettes moi c'est moi tu sais
on est d'accord je vais vous dire un
truc terrible
c'est dans le journal des goncourt
que tu connais léon daudet souhaité
cherchiez dans la fiche de ses maîtres
voilà comment tu sais ça jusqu'à ce que
gagnent moi qui ai envoyé un texto pour
me donner l'information ah ouais ouais
t'es un scoop c'est un peu c'est dans
tous les textes envoyés aussi
honnêtement elle se trouve odieux là
ouais tu n'écoutes pas confondre parle
mais pas du tout aimé d'aironi tu as
posé trois questions j'ai expliqué que
les hommes les trois femmes dont on
parle et n'a pas tu n'as pas été si on
parlait pas avec l'idée de la soirée une
espèce d'énorme révolte en ce moment
mais c'est pas un fossé entre les hommes
et les femmes ab non mais c'est pas un
fossé c'est que c'est fini c'est que
maintenant il faut être homosexuel je
sais pas d'où le terme exact je pense
c'est fini entre les hommes et les
femmes arabes ces événements mais je
veux être homosexuel je pense que c'est
la solution c'est mon rêve c'est mon
rêve
dans l'amour dure trois ans est ce que
tu avais pas déjà tout dit finul je
pensais écrire un roman sur un phénomène
qui est la disparition de l'amour
durable les complexités de rester avec
quelqu'un pendant longtemps et et en
même temps je me suis aperçu que c'était
une
sorte de damnation de destin qui lui est
tombé dessus en écrivant ce titre juste
ce titre appartient motul a écrit ces
deux gars une aventure qui a duré plus
de trois et deux nuls rennes ah ouais ce
jour là ouais c'était assez lui la
raison ce qui l'est c'est une
malédiction cirque a pris il a cru que
ça allait durer parce que on est tous
pareils évidemment on espère que ça dure
éternellement et à chaque fois au bout
de trois ans ça s'arrête donc maintenant
dessus quand une fille leur encontre
elle sait qu'en 2008 s'était elle est
super il est libre et peut prendre un
car voilà le plus long j'étais resté
avec un mec sait combien que
sept ans je crois sept ans c'est bien
attends je compte sept ans de réflexion
la taille à maurice qui revoit un peu
oui non mais oui mais alors c'est comme
la sienne où vous dansez dans quel film
norman quatre mariages où elle fait la
liste de ses ex tu sais et l'autre il
est là
mais tu as plus longtemps que tu es
resté qu'un mec sait combien
12 ans tous là là là là
ma fille et de ses membres s'est jamais
arrivé un homme et oncomethylome
présentant cinq
on est là
on a l'impression que c'est un truc avec
toi tu irais beaucoup plus encore non
moins dix ans et que la première 20 en
battant avec la deuxième avec la
prochaine
c'est bon c'est quoi ces du steak je
vais parce que c'est de là où j'étais
bien
pourquoi bilatéraux sont beaucoup de
notes au poids de ses choix c'est si
jaro de superbes enfin bravo eric
fréchon prédisent pas avec notre
cuisinier
c'est pas le style de la maison puis
j'ai avalé son côté arlette laguiller
suisse a
nettement gens voir la parfaite nous
nous on cherche pas le prince charmant
on cherche l'esclave sexuelle ce qui
n'est pas la même chose raison il ya une
esclave défiance change c'est que nous
aussi les femmes on cherche de muscade
sexuellement ont fait croire ça donc on
magasine dans l
est ce que vous savez très bien que les
mecs qui se voit de nouveau magazine le
journal local prince charmant c'est pour
nous pour l'esclave sexuelle
l'image de maurice en cuir
je ne sais pas pourquoi il a un truc
comme ça
saint maurice j'ai tout
ce mois l'essm a bon espoir est que j'ai
tout fait en je te rappelle je te rates
un show tout est là
la chose je soit appelée la ville aux
médias tu as déjà été esclave sexuelle
qua non mais j'en ai eu plein
-c'est-à-dire même étoile a germé
télescope sexuelle mamac ckoi l'esclave
sexuelle fille qui fait tout ce qu'on
leur dit bon bah c'est pas pour
portables simples est situé trouve du
plaisir
des heures qui sont très serrés mois
n'est pas du tout branché cul ouais mon
île mais qui pourrait servir à bon et
moi par exemple il ya des mais qu'il
préférait entre un bon dostoïevski et un
organe
aussi fédérer mais de taille et skiset
un orgasme probablement c'est quoi ce
n'est quelques uns qui me disait à aller
vas-y
qui choisit l'argenterie louis l'alena
les sables s'attend à faire il avoue que
ça te plaît oui très joli on aurait pu
se mettre ensemble finalement
là pour lui c'est pas un mec c'est un
futur
c'est un mec gentil
c'est les femmes et pourquoi est ce
qu'on s'est dit maintenant on n'a pas
vraiment changé c'est les femmes
changent et les femmes est-ce que moi on
cherche la peau chavirer si bien c'est
moi qui me fais large et intuit n'ai
jamais changé tout essayé tout c'est à
dire mais non
même le travail est un touche pour tout
essayé avant de dire que c'est fini non
mais
quelle que soit ta bonne volonté ça a
été plus
fort 61 c'est gratuit non c'est vrai que
le problème c'est que dès qu'on s'ennuie
cinq minutes on pense que c'est un drap
si ça il ya eu cinq ans même message en
ce que ces pagnes aux couples c'est
aussi lié à l'individu c'est que quand
on est seul on pense qu'on s'ennuie
quand on est en couple on pense qu'on
s'ennuie en fait voilà amuser un peu
tout seul à la maison mais la raison à
s'ennuyer à part prendre un sens oui je
suis d'accord avec toi sinon une société
de
consumériste de consumérisme ou en fait
plus on en a plus on s'ennuie mais c'est
normal puisqu'on nous demande bien de
faire tout seul on nous fait tout on
nous mâche le boisé bien sûr est très
bien s'il allait bien et ce petit qui
est dans ce ventre quel monde lui
préparons nous à
un monde ex
leonardo sciascia lui bergé je suis
obligé d'être un peu jaloux ouais mais
branché sans arrêt
trois-rivières si j'en ai est ce que
c'est vraiment est ce que c'est vrai
parce que c'est un truc qui m'a raconté
un jour dans une émission est ce que
c'est vrai qu'elle regarde la télé en
pyjama avec des grosses chaussettes et
un plateau repas sur les genoux ça c'est
terrible c'est vrai non non c'est elle
et on misait de satin sur l'hymne avec
leonardo dicaprio on
s'entend bien mais très bien je dis dans
le film de klapisch l'auberge espagnole
quand elles étaient 1 quand elle était
en dessous
moi je suis d'accord je le fais tu es
pas du pierre toi aussi
guêpier
fantasme eudes maurice est beaucoup plus
amer petits bateaux à sa bascule qu'est
ce qui s'est passé balle azulejos qu
on m'appelle on appelle jennifer lopez
n'a pas fait la couv la personne de m et
donc c'est penelope cruz c'est pas les
américains quand
on se fait pas c'est non je ne peux pas
dire qu'il sait et c'est quelqu'un
ça va envoyer c'est pour
sans mais c'est qui c'est une meuf ouais
c'est une
non toi tu ne me touches mais vraiment
match au toit c'est une messe et une
tu avais
moi c'est pas dégueulasse à une
conception de la femme vraiment qui
ravale la femme au rang de protéger
vraiment déclarés mais non c'est une
fille qui s'appelle les pieds c'est la
peur si c'est une amie qui
m'écrit c'est à dire comment vas tu
sais toute personne je peux dire des
initiales ou pas ouais une personne
d'une certaine notoriété mais dira amira
casar vas-y jean-paul moi je vais
balancer des séquences ya la violence
les initiales sur valence des initiales
on regarde sa tête ait pas d'accord
vas-y tu es prêt tu sauras lépi doit
déjà
peu balancé maintenant on s'attend alors
à l'initial contre initial moi je donne
les initiales de haine de notre ami jean
paul bachy région d'ascoli les piquet
dont il est une réponse à l'image de
lens d'initiation vaziani chez le bébé
alors vas-y lui c'est une niche albanais
alors le texto c'était un texto de aaa
le groupe
des alcooliques anonymes
et symbolique anonyme
5 millions de
noms je suis pas mariage
vous êtes athée mariage meurice toi je
rappelle que j'ai dit oui oui oui
philippe auguste à l'époque s'était
mariée pour les intérêts des régions 1
et philippe que philippe auguste qui est
jeune qui doit re 17 ans il rencontre
anna qui est jeune qui a 16 ans mais ils
sont vraiment amoureux vraiment et c'est
pas un mariage arrangé ils se marient
tout il rentre dans la chambre de noces
pour la nuit de noces à la saison et de
l'art 17 ans 18 ans lui
dix minutes après il sort il a dit fait
annuler ce mariage je vais plus jamais
l'avoir de ma vie philipp paulus la
vierge non c'est pas ça ce qu'elle était
vierge qui a été vérifié et vérifier
avant le mariage et c'est un secret
d'histoire on ne sait pas elle est
rentrée dans un couvent et elle a fini
sa vie dans un couvent et hamacs
pas possible c'était un mec
alors je vais te dire un truc
excuse moi elle était bretagne ça veut
dire brain ça veut dire quoi la femme du
comte de chambord était bretagne c'est à
dire qu'ils étaient barrées boraine
c'est ce qu'on dit des juments sac avait
un os qui bat alisa chasse qui barrait
son utérus et un côté country qui paraît
si
tu veux pas avoir quoi plutôt songer à
pénétration pas l'accouchement elle
était brûlée et peut-être que la femme
de philippe auguste étaient brûlés
brh a parlé j'ai
encore une droguée
ya ma fiancée qui vient de mes seins
texto un qui sort d'une projet les dans
le coin jeudi passé comme ça au moins ça
va régler tous un rôle entier
non pas tu fais ça on mène on n'a pas
droit mais non
non seulement c'est une amie mais c'est
un auteur vendeur c'est un auteur que
j'ai reçue était officialisée
mais pas du tout les trois cas c'est bon
je sors on est au dîner encore là et
donc on se disait ben pas si tu veux tu
sonnes atea c'est sa 4e
ok je te souhaite
dépenser hachey caderonne t'as vu c'est
pas sympa c'est un compliment
un complément de merde c'est un beau but
sinon c'est pas d'accord c'est un
compliment de merde
plus mauvaise que ce sens soulignant
qu'ottawa
chicken run
tabac n'arrive pas tout ça c'est un
dessin animé en pâte à modeler ne s'est
pas couché
niamey
c'est ce que je sais c'est une petite
fille ou quoi je souhaite beaucoup de
bonheur tous les deux à
un monde dû tourner un film ambitieux
intelligent comme tu vas rire mais je te
quitte et avec une femme et qu'après il
te dit tu ressembles à une poule en hâte
à modeler non c'est bien un monde où
l'homme et la femme ne se comprennent
plus
c'est vrai l'homme et la femme ne se
comprennent plus ça doit faire ce qu'il
est célibataire et l'armée ses yeux
bleus avant il était seul à seul
écrivain français
soyons tous homosexuels
nous n'avons pas peur cool regarde mon
père et les bulls jeudi que les castrais
le cerveau dit monsieur je chantage
manche évidemment rien je vous promets
aux
ça donne des malheurs et les palatins
fillon si on l'avait la rivalité a été
sur les choses
mais il m'a dit qu'elle vient jamais ce
qu'elle est avec un os quand est ce
qu'on peut se faire une auto devant tout
le monde est-ce qu'on pourrait répéter
sacrée soirée
mémoire musicale un groupe lui a sauté
note c'est un
choix au
quatrième étage
[Musique]
qui
l arène vachement owen
je note à where we
pattinson quand il sonne
[Musique]
jean pierre foucault
tu sais que j'ai j'ai tout ton nom
pendant 3 heures par garde temps comment
ça va tu que je te lève ton manteau et
que je les deux nageurs
est ce que tu crois pas belgique contre
les hommes et les femmes il ya un truc
assez
froid là bing un truc
mais un truc est cassé et l'intriqué
casse et bien voilà moi c'est un
[Musique]
truc bien fait de casser
quand tu mon bien truquée la rue guy
cassiers on n'a pas le choix ce soir
c'est ce
qu'il a dit de toi avant que tu arrives
ces normes ouais ouais c'est john a dit
elle arrive à quelle heure où tes mains
et espagne vraiment sincères aquitaine
comme ça tu qui est incroyable c'est ce
qu'on a envie d'enfant ce que les gens
peuvent voter je connais jean paul ii
puis quoi à 3,4 ça fait trois quatre
césars qu'on se connaît messi
eh bien je connais jean paul depuis pas
mal d'années est gelée rarement mais moi
c'est pareil j'ai jamais vu dans ce
dédale ben jamais jamais incroyable
incroyable il a dit je crois que cette
fois c'est la bonne
non bien les bonnes
je crois que c'est faux si
tu vas pas dit je crois que c'est cette
fois elle est bonne
celle là catherine
catherine lara ouais bah voilà une qahba
attendu pour être prêt dit
on était en train de dire avec frédéric
beigbeder qu'on allait devenir pdg
toi aussi c'est ce que je disais et toi
tu es devenu p des biens avant nous et
chez toi qu'à raison finalement
catherine tu vois c'est toujours moi qui
ai un truc est rompu entre les mecs et
les filles
non mais sérieux dans les séries avec
mother en grèce soit un truc et rompuy
un truc est bon on voit des fibres des
garçons c'est quoi
voilà ce que se dit
alors tous les cas en tous les cas tiens
voilà mais voilà ben voilà catherine la
catherine lara est d'accord avec une
bonne tasse de thé
et le fossé creusé entre les hommes et
les femmes c'est pas le bijou que va
faire acquérir dossier conséquent bien
ce que tu veux
[Musique]
rise
chimay bwin
wendy cadbury
winnezeele mouche à vis des
[Musique]
reprises de travail nouvelles demandes
walchi ce matin
charles laughton
ça
des prix ok à outils alors on est déviée
japon n'est d'état pioline est on est
vieux c'est l'étape pioline
[Musique]
aime bien s'en tape out et alors et
alors
alors on leur dit vicent foot aiment la
paix mais bien
[Musique]
souvent de regarder la poutre non mais
attends maurice boyer la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'une nana qui dit je veux avoir
un enfant avec toi c'est que tu vas
avoir des rapports sans capote avec elle
plein de fois et là c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais tu imagines qu'il faut se
réjouir pour lui un rapport sans capote
et sans argent
n'existe pas
ça c'est ce qu'on voit dans les contes
de fées
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu